so let's just understand the question
first what makes this a challenging
question it's a good curveball throw is
that when you have a look at this thing
you don't know how big this is so we're
actually talking about this morning one
of the strategies for people who don't
who aren't as good at dealing with
binomials it's just just expand the damn
thing don't think you know just just
write everything out and then hopefully
we'll see something but you can't do
this won't play ball with you okay cuz
it's like when do you stop writing like
are there 10 terms 11 like a thousand
times you can't do it okay so this
requires that actually makes this
question quite hard to access which is
why they've given you the answer right
because you don't want to get all the
way through and like I have no idea
whether I'm on the right track or not I
think the most helpful tool here I'm
sorry let me just come back the reason
why you look at the solution you're like
oh boy where did the X Co the X just
disappears if you have a look the reason
why the X disappears is because what
this question is interested in is the
coefficients which is just the numbers
okay so therefore once I've worked out
which the not which are the numbers I'm
interested in you can ignore the X's you
can ignore all the X's the question is
really all about the ends and the case
alright and what their relationship is
so probably the best tool for this is
going to be a tool that we actually use
this morning for the tool here which is
to first work out what the general term
of this is what is the general term in
this expansion so what is this thing
equal to well it's the sum of a number
of terms that all look very very similar
okay let's have a look at this thing so
I'm going to start from the zero term
and being that this power up here is n
I'm going to count from zero all the way
up to M when you include zero of course
that means there are n plus 1 terms in
total in whatever this expansion will be
okay that's how many things aren't
adding up what are the three components
that always occurred every single term
ok so the first one is the binomial
coefficient okay now in this case if
this was the power of 3 then this would
be 3 throughs not 3 trees one 3 etc this
time the power is n so that's why
there's an N up here and the AH
signifies which term by looking at right
now
there's the binomial coefficient and
then you've got some of these and some
of these alright some of these are some
of these now I can write this I'm just
gonna do it up the top in two different
ways okay I can start with these being
big and then they get smaller and
smaller and smaller or I can start with
this being big and it gets smaller
smaller now I'm gonna write both and
then I'm gonna ask you to tell me which
one is an obvious choice to do in our
actual working so if I started with this
one it starts from zero then it's gonna
be 1 ^ ah because the first term has R
equals 0 it starts at 0 and it counts up
so how many of the other things are
there there will be a be careful it's n
minus R because these will always add up
to M does that make sense
so here's one version that I could put
it here the other version counting from
the other direction is to say well it's
these guys that count down and it's
these guys that count up now you tell me
which is easier to deal with
clearly the right-hand one right because
look you've got to put this messy n
minus R power somewhere you might as
well attach it to one because then you
don't really need to worry about it okay
so therefore I'm going to write that 1 1
n minus R X on k ^ ah okay
therefore the nth term along is going to
be turn in sorry term R is a better way
to say it because that's the thing
that's changing um it's gonna be NCR I'm
just gonna write it out like so and then
I can simplify
like that okay now let's have a look at
this this thing here tells us what every
single term alone will be and I want the
x squared term in the X cubed term which
ones are they going to be term what in
term what now have a look if I try it R
equals 3 I'm gonna have NC 3x on K to
the power of 3 that'll be the X cubed
term because that's the only X happening
so you make that three you make this X
cubed I also want so I'll write that
down turn 3nc 3x on K cubed I also want
that x squared so so how am I gonna do
that
so to sweat okay now at this point I
mean you don't have to do this but it
does make it up this one tiny bit we
don't have to right I'm only interested
in the coefficients so therefore I would
say if we define if the terms are T 3 T
2 then I'm just going to call the
coefficients C 3 and C 2 C 3 which is
just the coefficients that I'm
interested in and C 3 will be part of it
and then you're going to have 1 over K
cubed you see I'm not interested in the
X's anymore I'm just interested in the
coefficient and then you've got this guy
which is 2 1 on K squared
okay I'm always there write the
coefficient of x cubed that this one is
twice this coefficient so therefore I'm
just gonna be lazy sorry this
coefficient is exactly double this
coefficient how's your brain doing okay
now what we've done is we've gone quite
a fair way right we're trying to sort
out how do we find these coefficients in
here so I use the general term to do
that and then in the general terms I'm
only interested in specific ones and the
coefficients within those specific ones
I'm almost there see how much you've
written over there is only ends in case
all right it's only ends in case so
that's one of reasons why they don't
care about the X's I'm just going to
need to expand this thing and make make
end the subject okay how am I going to
do that okay so I can take reciprocals
of some things now I will take
reciprocals in a minute but I don't
really necessarily need to right away
because have a look at this right this
nc3 business and this one on K cubed and
C 2 this is 2 on K squared there's
another way to overcome the fractions in
this I don't have to take reciprocals
even though I can I could just maybe
multiply both sides by something
convenient what would be a convenient
choice
how about cuz I wanna get rid of all the
fractions
how about K cubed is that okay right so
cancel cancel cancel cancel that's
that's progress
isn't it that's good now all I'm left
with is this MC 3 on this side and then
NC 2 times 2 K now to make any more
progress
do you notice I have NCR terms here and
I don't have any over here so I'm going
to have to unpack these things so I need
to know what these are equal to without
the abbreviation so do you remember I'll
give you a clue it's a fraction what's
on the top and factorial R factorial
which in this case is 3 M minus R which
is in this case n minus 3 okay that's
going to translate over here and then
don't forget that 2 K that's still
hanging around ok now this looks messy
and intimidating but really isn't as bad
as it looks because look cancel cancel
the two factorial in here is hiding
inside these 3 factorial I cancel if I
divide both sides what's left it's just
the 3 by the same logic and be careful
here you've got n minus 3 factorial and
n minus 2 factor one of these is hiding
in the other usually we'd say a small
factorial is hiding inside a big one
which one of these is bigger this one is
bigger isn't it that's that's sneaky
right because the number but this not
very smaller but it's actually a bigger
thing and you can imagine because the
next term down in fact I'm even going to
write this what have I got over here
this is 1 on 3 n minus 3 factorial right
if you ever get confused about this like
I was getting confused about it 30
seconds ago do that unrolling thing we
talked about remember that so this guy
here is n minus 2 times the next one
smaller which is n minus 3 n minus 4 I
don't need to write all those it's just
that ok cancel cancel the next line is
almost there isn't it two fractions
cross multiply what do you end up with
on the Left you're just going to have n
minus 2 6 K and then your next line
isn't that one okay let me make sure we
understand because the most important
thing about this is not the number
crunching is it right
in fact probably once I wrote down
may-maybe when I got to here you're like
oh I see the rest of this can just
collapse
okay the first thing you need to do is
in order to work with this thing to get
coefficients out of it you have to be
able to know what what are each of the
terms so that's why I appeal to the
general term then you've got a noble
which of the general terms are really
relevant to me and then you use the
information in the question itself to
relate those two together and then and
then you just have to know some
definitions of terms okay